12 months ago I had a meeting with a man
who changed my [ __ ] life he called me
on my [ __ ] and he made me put this
event together he was my inspiration
he's your inspiration too ladies
gentlemen welcome to the stage expired
by 2017 real quick there's no CV for the
K in my last night ha ha ha ha clapping
whoa um somebody's getting fired so
must've been I actually have a t-shirt
that says no see before the K thank you
so much for the warm welcome super
pumped please sit down let's get into
this
the fog machine is pretty intense uh
yeah I mean you know there's couple
things I want to talk about but more
realistically I want to really focus on
doing some QA because I think a lot of
you that are here have seen my spiel and
you can hear my sick and I don't think
there's any reservations or lack of
content out there about what I think I
think the world is in an incredible
place I think we're all so lucky to be
alive during time where the Internet is
hitting maturity that allows for an
enormous amount of opportunity the truth
is a lot of people squander it and
because they're looking for shortcuts
my biggest fear as I stand on this stage
today is not only here in this room but
in the entire market I think everybody's
just genuinely looking for it to happen
quicker than it actually happens I think
one of the great things that's going on
for me right now with d-roc secured up
for d-roc
one of the cool things about having the
rock now document I was saying backstage
how much I wish that I've been vlogging
when I started at Wine Library because I
think it would be important for
everybody here to have the context of
watching 10 years of working in a liquor
store every single day for 15 hours a
day in a blog you've heard this story
you know my background but the reality
is it's very hard to quantify unless you
see it where you feel it but is
legitimate how many people here under 35
raise your hands yeah I mean like the
level of disrespect I have for anybody
under 35 that wants it tomorrow is so
high in a good way I'm not mad at you I
just think that it's a very interesting
time to be alive because the Internet
gives us opportunity for things to
happen quick but the reality is the
people in this room that will win are
the ones that take it slow I think my
energy and the way I roll speaks to a
lot of fast paced stuff but if you
really peel away what I'm talking about
it's just super old-school I very much
more associate with 70 and 80 year olds
than I do with 20 and 30 year olds about
the way this goes down and so if I look
if I could say anything it's the
following there there's no system
there's no process there's no thing
that's going to make it happened faster
there's only a couple of driving through
things number one if you don't provide
real actual value to people in exchange
for the money that you're asking for in
return you will lose over time it
happens every time you might be able to
make some quick cash but you will never
win long term and you will go through
the same [ __ ] over and over there are
plenty of 30 40 50 year olds in here who
go up and down up and down up and down
because their stuff is horseshit and
it's not coming from the right place and
they're looking to make a quick buck and
some character on stage says that they
got a process that's going to make it
happen fast and they're wrong so that's
number one number two
you're living at a time where you're
competing against everybody else when I
just make this perfectly clear it has
[ __ ] awesome as it is that it doesn't
cost anything to produce content and put
it on the social web you're competing
with everybody else when I take out my
phone and I go through Instagram and
Facebook I'm not just competing with
people that write business books or put
out entrepreneurial content
I'm competing with people that talk
about football and milk and parenting
and gardening and the news and the
weather there is one stream and we're
all competing for that attention so I
highly recommend that what you put out
has a chance of succeeding while you
also put out as much content as possible
to break through let me break down what
I believe in and then I really want to
go into QA I believe that there's only
one thing that connects every single
person in this room which is at the end
of the day it is our job to story tell
to other human beings what our feel is
about and then we want something to
happen right you may be trying to raise
money for the PTA or you may be running
for mayor or you might be trying to sell
sneakers or a program or a process or
your music or your art but at the end of
the day the only thing that every single
person here is actually combined by is
that you're fighting for somebody's
attention and then you have to say
something and then you're hoping
something that happens what I have done
really well in my career is that I've
always been really good at intuitively
understanding where people's attention
was when most of the people in this room
didn't yet I launched an e-commerce
business in 1996 when people thought
selling wine on the internet was crazy
there are people in this room and
definitely the parents of people in this
room that thought the internet was a fad
that was a real conversation there's a
lot of youngsters in here but for some
of us with a little more gray hair the
internet being a fad was a real
conversation in 1990 2 3 4 5 6 like
would it even be around right then I did
email marketing how many people here
have done email marketing in there
perfect in 1996 seven I have an email
newsletter of two hundred thousand
people buying wine with 91% open rates
not because I'm so great
but because nobody was doing it and
that's what it was it wasn't it was such
a good headline writing it wasn't that
it was so smart it was that nobody was
doing email marketing and when how many
people here were on email in 1997 raise
your hands raise them higher so all of
you remember what I remember about email
1997 which is we read every [ __ ] word
of every single email it's what we did
because we're just supply and demand
right like you treated it like actual
mail you're like [ __ ] I better read this
free money from the Congo cool you know
like like click like literally then
Google AdWords came out the day Google
AdWords came out I started buying lying
terms on it for five cents a click and I
owned those terms for almost a year
before anybody bid me up so while most
people didn't even know it existed
I was arbitrage in people's attention
because I thought people were searching
and I was extracting sales this is a
game and a system by the way that is
free zero dollars and zero cents that
will always be tried and true where is
the attention of the end consumer where
do most people think it is meaning
that's overpriced as we stand here today
print ads radio ads for the most part
television billboards Direct Mail a ton
of programmatic banners and other
digital assets on the internet and where
is it underpriced
as we sit here today no matter what you
sell Facebook Instagram influencers
snapchat filter open marketplace if
you're marketing to people under 30 and
where is it going to go very soon that
it's not five or ten years away consumer
virtual reality is far away do you need
to make your products and service map to
that I don't think so not for next year
the year after
but as Alexa voice and Alexis skills is
podcasting as a media company or as
advertising is that here at scale very
close and here if you're doing podcast
advertising and definitely if you're
good enough to be a podcast so basically
here's what I think I think that
information is commoditized there's so
much information on the internet it's
hard to sell information in my opinion
and feel good about it because there's
so much of it there's a reason my
content is free it's because the supply
and demand of content is harder than
ever to sell and differentiate if you
want to feel great about it because
there's so much content is your $300
thing actually available for four hours
of google searching is your $100 thing
actually available for nine dollars and
save you time as you debate it so that's
what I think about I think that it runs
tried-and-true for everybody I think
there's a couple things that really make
sense to me like this rule you know zero
people zero people that actually created
wealth I don't mean your lucky friend
who inherited his grandmother's money I
mean you don't know anybody on earth
that created an actual business and made
wealth without working their [ __ ]
face off there is no such thing as
passive income it doesn't exist you
might have something that's working for
a little while because you did landing
page optimization and you figured out
how to arbitrage Google for a few
seconds aka couple years but that will
go away when Google changes its
algorithm or when people go to mobile
devices or when Facebook becomes more
important which means it was working for
24 months or 16 but now it's not which
is everything but passive because you
start building your life on it and then
when [ __ ] hits the fan you have to
adjust and it really [ __ ] you up so
these are the big things that I think
about
which is why are so many people looking
for shortcuts when life is long why are
people not willing to do the tried and
true thing when if you just audit every
single situation it's always the same
thing which is the people that run
marathons win and the people that are
running sprints lose and it's because
people lack patience people are seduced
by stuff people make all their decisions
on short-term money because they want
stuff people are insecure and want to
posture in front of other people that
they're successful there's just a
million [ __ ] reasons why you do it
but it just doesn't make it right
so come on a little bit of a mission you
know like my big thing is I build other
businesses and then the garyvee stuff is
kind of like out there and doesn't think
sure it leads to opportunities but for
me it's I'm on a mission for legacy
around this I'm not you know I'll get
I'll get paid to come and speak I'll
write my books but I'm not trying to
create content as a top of the funnel
thing to sell something at scale I'm not
against that I know the far majority
people want to do that Mazel Tov knock
yourself out it's just not the way I see
it because I don't think that's how the
trends play out and if you're good
enough you don't need it so these are
things that keep playing over and over
in my mind over and over in my mind over
and over in my mind stakes are high
opportunities very high the competition
is real every single person in this room
is competing with each other no matter
how they position or slightly position
it because we're going into an attention
that we only have so much attention time
is the asset uber one of the great
misses of my career because I passed on
the angel round twice and that $50,000
investment would be worth 300 million
dollars and that [ __ ] pisses me off
uber I misunderstood because I thought
that uber was selling transportation but
what I realized when I invested it a
little bit later so I'll do okay is that
uber sells time and even funnier uber
sells the perception of time you think
you can I mean I stand in New York City
all the time waiting for my
watching cabs drive by me so I'm
fascinated by consumer trends I
absolutely think about always what do
people actually do why are you doing
what you do why are people in this room
going hiking going to conferences going
to Coachella going to matches just so
they can take the selfie and show people
what they're doing what's that about
does that mean event marketing is more
important than ever does we are doing
more stuff than ever now because we are
painting our lives to people through our
pictures more than ever thus forcing us
to do [ __ ] just for the picture how do
you think about these things that a
macro is very important to me it's a
super important thing of how I think
about the psychology of human beings so
much of what I actually do and you can
see the tone that I brought here tonight
I want you to understand why I do the
things I do because I know that the
tactics I've laid out over and over and
over and over again
you guys can forbade them repeat some of
my [ __ ] it's you need to understand why
because the only thing that will ever
have value is if you understand people
and you try to desperately figure out
how to provide them more value than
you're asking for them in return and
that is where almost everybody breaks
everybody is selfish you want the money
you want the thing you don't want to
provide more value than that thing is
worth you actually want to do it the
other way and by the way when I say you
I'm not talking about this room just on
the whole [ __ ] game everybody it's
why so few people break through because
when everybody's doing the same [ __ ]
they don't win and all these systems
look the [ __ ] same and they all do
the same thing it forces everybody in
the same behavior and then there's a
reason why a few people break through
because they go the other way
everybody goes left to go right that's
where all the [ __ ] action is all the
action is in one place
in a world where everybody is creating
content for the internet which is where
everybody's eyes are over and over only
a few can break through because they're
providing more value in return and they
have patience to not ask for money in
the up front but they actually build
something and then are able to extract
value later so it's in it super basic
how I think about it I am I don't think
we're going backwards I think what I
just talked about is getting compound ly
worse and more optimistic it depends on
where you are you'll get more value if
you over provide you'll get less value
if you follow the masses I think that
it's really hard to be patient I'm
empathetic you may have debt you may
have things you want to do I'm super
empathetic I really am the problem is it
doesn't change the reality of what it is
you know just you know I don't notice a
like and I want to remind everybody you
can say easy for you to say Gary Vee did
it I just want to remind everybody I
only give advice that I ate from 22:32
for 12 years of my life I worked seven
days a week in a liquor store every
[ __ ] day and gave up everything I
worked so it's 15 [ __ ] 16 hours a day
every single day I did not have one
Saturday off in my 20s
none biggest day of the week none
literally literally literally 99% of the
people in this room will take more
Saturday's off tomorrow then I took off
in my entire 20s it's just true like
like I just need people to know how it
happens I'm very beautiful that you see
me flying around with [ __ ] d-roc and
you think that's what happened this is
just a lot of work a lot of work and I'm
don't forget I'm also rogue I gave up on
school right around fourth grade so I
was willing to take these and apps and
let them push me through the system so I
could learn how to sell baseball cards
and do all my things so I've been on
this for my whole [ __ ] life
and so I don't know I think
entrepreneurship in a very weird place
where everybody thinks they are one I
think everybody thinks they're an
entrepreneur because
write it in their Instagram bio and I
think that that's not going to work out
I really don't and I think
self-awareness is something we need to
talk more about you may be great at
sales you may be an entrepreneur you may
be created operations you might be
really good at finance and math the more
you can put yourself in a position of
what you do best instead of trying to be
something else the more you will succeed
it's black and white it's true it's
forever you just might be super creative
and you haven't sold [ __ ] in your life
like it's really weird to all of a
sudden be really into selling when you
never sold anything for the first twenty
five years of your life I was ripping
people's [ __ ] flowers out of the yard
when I was four and trying to sell it
back to them that's DNA you know what I
mean I mean it though I'm not trying to
become a CFO now just because I know
it's good financial arbitrage and I just
I don't know I'm worried that
everybody's getting pushed into things
that they're not instead of blocking it
out than going all in on who they are
because that's just where it's going to
be that just tried and true so my my
kind of serious tone here for tonight is
predicated on the bubble that I fear the
bubble of all this is easy and it's
happening if it is not there are so few
startups that are actually going to make
money and when we spend all our time
focusing on snapchat and Facebook and
these couple of once-in-a-generation
things we don't talk like for every
Instagram there's 40,000 insta [ __ ] and
so I do not want to be part of the
pyramid scheme of success I want to talk
about what's actually happening and
what's actually happening is every day
things get more competitive and forces
you to actually bring more value to the
end-user so if you think you're going to
mail in if you think it's about your
marketing let me tell you something as a
big-time [ __ ] marketer the best
marketing in the world doesn't fix your
[ __ ] product like if your product sucks
you [ __ ] lost and so I know you think
you're [ __ ] products awesome you
think your kids are cute they're [ __ ]
ugly
I know why you want it to work and so I
don't know I am I really want to put you
in a mindset of the work and of the
value because it's the only thing that
has ever won ever ever I want to get
ready for Q&A so let's get the mics
going to give a question stop putting up
your hands let's definitely go with that
little girl who went first I think you
hold on hold on hold on what's your name
little girl my name is Tegan Helen how
are you good good
say I know he's so much on your old
spoon okay
and I took some gift for you
well I'd like them do you want to come
up here and give them to me
[Applause]
hi how are you thank you can I have a
hug yeah all right thank you thank you
this you you've written three books
jesus [ __ ] christ amazing great shot
awesome all right question for the mics
go ahead wherever you want to go all
right
anybody got a mic yeah let's just go to
go to somebody there we go
stand I go what's your name my name is
Andrey Andrey Andrey I'm like I guess I
got it from Columbia South America very
nice and I'm a photographer okay I have
never known if it's a blessing or you
know like like a curse yeah right so my
business right now for the thing that
I'm doing in Instagram is trying to
become like a destroyer of photography
in a sort of way I think good I think
good pictures but I want to send a
message to other artists about thinking
that art is not what it used to be like
you cannot make money or a living out of
it you should actually try to be more of
a personality around it so my question
is how would you market this idea so you
want to be somebody that tells other
artists that it's not about selling the
art it's that you need to build a
personal brand and be the personality
behind the art and then that's the
monetization because then people will
buy your art or because then you can do
something else the second part places
that that was actually like pursuing art
for the sake of being art and monetizing
if you want it by doing some something
around it I mean I first I would not
tell them how to monetize so the biggest
artists in the world are self promoters
and marketers of their brand and then
they sell the art so the first one to me
is a far more interesting conversation
because
artists are artists for a reason there's
a reason all those people want to take
those photos or paint those pictures
it's because it's what they're good at
or they like or it's what they loved so
forcing them into like forget that the
art is the gateway for you be a personal
brand and monetize that I think it's
just a bad strategy right
you just have entrepreneurial DNA in you
that happen to match along with the art
and that's actually a rarity right most
people don't carry both this is what I'm
to be very frank concerned up the
thought that the model is let's take
them out from what they want to do or
they want to be doing and I'm going to
teach them how to build a personal brand
the first question becomes why are you
the right person to do that like have
you done that yeah I'm doing it like day
to day since January that I came across
your accounting doing what doing what
what do you mean like how they have you
made money not being the artist but
you're making money using art as the
gateway ah yeah the second part that you
say how how are you making money uh well
I started by taking the pictures and
selling them okay and so what I have
done is taking your advice of narrating
my reality day-to-day you know what
right now I'm not like making a living
out of doing this I'm just building like
the vlogs to get there because of
negatives bad strategy so say so first
notes okay it's a good strategy here's
the problem too many people want to go
into teaching people how to make money a
different way before they've actually
ever made money without making money
teaching people how to make money I mean
for me what gave me the audacity to talk
about business was in my 20s for 12
years without saying a [ __ ] word to
anybody
I built a 60 million dollar retail
business that made me feel like oh let
me tell you what I did or what I thought
about so I think the big thing that
concerns me is I think vlogging and
building awareness and documenting
that's good because that's going to
bring you attention my friends attention
is the currency of our society the
number one arbitrage in our world it's
called fame
right get real famous and the weirdest
[ __ ] happens people give you everything
for free makes no sense it's bad you
know like it's the number one arbitrage
so getting people to care about you for
you and your journey is important what
you do with that power and how you make
money is even more important that's the
thing to think about so I would say
before you tell people how to make money
about it you need to do that for
yourself first figure out what that was
and then do it okay thank you very much
you're welcome hi hi first of all I
can't believe that I get to win the
thing another picture with you and then
I get to ask you a question and I'm not
going good it really is okay so hi I'm
Alex my question is this my husband and
I have a business which we love we have
lots of singing schools around the parts
of England where we're from and we have
got to a stage where we have to make a
decision whether we want to get a big
mammal own and go all around the UK or
did grow slowly and organic yup which
one number two well remember number two
is what I like yeah you may like number
one here's what I don't like I never
like borrowing a lot of money when the
economy has been good for eight years it
just feels like guys people get over
leveraged like if you like having credit
card debt to invest into your business
it's not fun what's fun about that like
all my friends who have startups who
raise four million dollars for their app
and lose money every month I've got news
for you it doesn't take a [ __ ] hero
to lose money each month like so look if
you're super confident what I would
rather you do is you've got how many you
memory we've got about 11 schools around
I would I would look at how profitable
you were running that business I would
look at what you're doing with the money
you make each year as in your personal
life and as in like what do you spend
the money on right does it make profit
it makes profit it's not a massive
profit but it does make some pay for
borrow and go open 49 you have 11
[ __ ] locations and you don't make a
lot of profit you need to [ __ ] make
the business better yeah because guess
what happens when you make your your
energy to making your 11 locations make
20% more money you actually have your
own money to expand go [ __ ] figure
yeah thank you go ahead my friend higher
yes
in terms of as you become more
successful a little louder if I actually
become more successful and more
opportunities open yeah yeah how do you
say no or what what filter do you use to
say no complete gut intuition I have no
[ __ ] idea how this dude got in front
of me for 20 minutes in London I'm being
dead serious
like my answer is intuition and it's the
complete vulnerability of how I'm
mapping my life and other people that
are crippled by opportunity the but the
biggest thing I do is I don't look back
and dwell you never know like I always
think about let's use the uber example
right
I might have invested in uber right and
I might have made 300 million dollars on
paper and that would have made me even
more Internet investment famous so maybe
I would have went to San Francisco to be
on Bloomberg West and talk about why I
invested in uber and maybe on that trip
I woulda got hit by car and died like
life is such a matrix so the reason I'm
able to navigate through intuition is
because I don't ever ever ever think
what if and I think way too many people
are looking backwards you guys the
amount of people in this room that are
thinking about [ __ ] that happened 16
years ago like what if I dated Donnie
Thompson [ __ ] Donnie Thompson
so so the real answer is intuition it's
always got my Northstar in mind which is
does this bring me attention or
awareness bring me into new audiences
does this make me the short-term dollars
I need to navigate my world is this
going to help me buy the New York Jets
these are all things that are running
through my mind but at the end of the
day be honest answer is gut call over
and over and over and never crying about
what happened Cheers
I got it my question is what is the best
mistake that you've made the best
mistake so all of them and I'll tell you
why it's a really funny question people
ask me about my mistakes my man I I make
so many mistakes like I make a mistake I
mean big mistakes often I haven't had
anything that is really trying to take
my best mistake probably my best
mistakes is watching some of the
companies that I passed on and investing
become successful and I knew that they
were good but I didn't love the idea and
it's teaching me how much it comes down
to the person more than ever in my life
in my 40s now do I believe it's about
the person and that some people can win
just by sheer will and brutal force and
so that's an interesting mistake for me
as companies are coming around but to be
very honest with you that's a fairly
[ __ ] answer and let me tell you why
it's a [ __ ] answer I spend so little
time on my mistakes it would make your
[ __ ] head spin I am incapable of
respecting my mistakes [ __ ] my mistakes
and that is a huge insight to how I
Drive and it's interesting that the last
question in this question have such a
similar thing like it is about moving
forward so I'm not sure I don't have a
classic on my resume where like this
thing [ __ ] up but the next time I saw
it I did at this thing and I won like I
don't have that cliche answer I default
into having mistakes every day trying to
learn from them but really not even
manifesting and realizing their mistakes
I just think they're part of the process
and that's not a look that's not a
razzing you up or like yeh like there's
no such thing as mistakes Donny
there's lists I [ __ ] lost money on a
hundred things I've done but if the
macro I did it that's why I don't like
being over leveraged right like I've
never made a mistake because I never put
myself in a position where this thing
kills me that's for the steak that's
right think about it
yep go ahead yeah hi guy how are you
I could I have read all of your butcher
named Tommy how are you good thank you
I'm one of those quiet fans that you
hate thank you no comments Veera yeah
but you're a lurker yeah I am I because
it's mostly because I I watched the
daily V show in the gym and I'm on the
treadmill or something we can get off or
something just like good job well I
really love the class and then look I'm
kidding I'm kidding go ahead um I run a
video production company and I worked
with sort of smaller luxury brands and
right you know bespoke luxury brand okay
and I've been running my business for
two years now before that I used to be a
TV producer for 5 years so I'm coming
from lack of content or region or
content background and my background is
mainly in reality shows and talk shows
and things like ok so I'm trying to find
a way to bring together branded content
and original content great and one
trying to do is sort of almost like a
female version of GQ so it's some sort
of like an online channel and that is
for female kind of business women who
are like real business women in hello
and so trying to create original content
for this and it's really hard because at
the same time I'm also running my
current business so I was wondering if
you have any ideas on because I'm
writing a pitch for it and trying to get
investment so I'm not entirely sure -
how sure that I will monetize it you
know when I go to investors so I hope
they don't like vice and refined
twenty-nine and and all these companies
you know BuzzFeed they've shown how a
media company can monitor let her hold
on to my clitoral dr. can monetize you
know this I think I don't think that's
necessarily because I'm going for a
niche market so I'm not a niche market
well female business women you know to
please the kind of women that will shop
from net reporter you know that I
understood what you're saying I don't
think it's a niche market okay I think
you're selling yourself out of it being
a niche market like I think you're
selling yourself up it's a huge I
literally don't know where to start from
to go from branded content because I
have a stable business now and it's
growing slowly so in the past two years
I started the business and it's been
growing growing really nicely so it's
kind of like finding the balance between
running the current business and the
transition well first and foremost
that's right I mean first and foremost
you have to understand you're looking to
become a publisher Yeah right yeah I
want I my aim my goal has always been
you want to become a publisher like
you're starting a brand that Conde Nast
or Hearst could start tomorrow if they
decided to go after the female business
right yeah that's hard and like real
hard and so like so I don't know if you
know did you see in January I bought a
company called pure well yeah right so
the work that goes into being a
successful publisher in today's internet
at scale that goes after a genre like
that is very very competitive
you're minimally going to need to raise
a couple million dollars just for the
tech and the infrastructure even if you
go freelance to create enough creative
you're also going to have to get a
co-founder who's in the tech business
yeah who's a builder because he or she
has to be a co-founder because you're in
the tech business by being a digital
publisher yeah you're also going to need
to really have somebody under team that
disproportionately understands how to
hack the Facebook Twitter Instagram
snapchat ecosystem to siphon audience
because there's no publisher right now
that's coming out and getting any growth
without being deeply integrated into the
Facebook ecosystem yeah so the thing
that I hear that I would recommend is
you get two co-founders okay because
you're busy yeah you're missing a lot of
the elements to have a prayer of anybody
writing you a check for your company
right part of me thinks to sort of let
it grow organically and build it from my
current business I've got a fact but it
is very difficult I mean I'm hoping to
make just over a quarter million this
year last year I did about half that and
and that started from zero just
literally I get it
so if my intuition is I love you
building it organically off the profits
of the first thing you're missing a one
probably two co-founders who are real
hardcore ninjas you will not win in
publishing in that space would you be
interested not me but you need them I
really think you need a tech founder and
a growth hacking quant based marketer to
get you traffic or you'll have zero
chance okay yeah awesome hi Gary hey
Matt hi my name is William and so I
talked about transition okay I think a
lot of people here go to transitions
when they go from one field to another
and okay become whatever business so in
your case and well I'll tell you in your
case in my case in my case I came from a
career of doing very well as an
architect and then we transition into
running a media company okay there were
several several channels so in your case
you were the white guy and I remember 10
years ago somebody told me all this is a
guy eating cereal with wine or something
yeah and I just looked at it and then
hold on but then what that made me
realize that eventually you open you
meet a sorry a pinare media can you take
everyone here a little bit into how did
you start it I know you had a $80,000
time it's your first time if I remember
correctly very good how do you perform
with that person and how did you move on
to that second time how did you start
doubling up doubling up
how did I get my first client since I
was branded in a different genre how did
I create credibility in a dead world
well I mean we already have times and
stuff we have a certain amount of
credibility because we communicate which
is saying what you realize to do well
yes it's just a different media
different mediums so alright Geoffrey's
lying that relationship how do you
manage that and then how you make it to
the second one by listening all right
that's the real answer right and hold on
to this because I want to make sure I
get to your answer somebody emailed me
something you know don't forget it was
coming to me a little bit because I
always do first that's a big problem in
the game I do first and let's [ __ ] come
to me I don't say that right
like I don't say I'm you know like that
that has no leverage then you're selling
I don't sell for [ __ ] I brand and market
and let's [ __ ] come to me so what I did
was to answer your question I'm gonna
love this you want to know the
straight-up answer to your question kids
me I spent 12 hours a day on Twitter in
2007 because I thought it was going to
be big amassed one of the largest
followings on Twitter and then Gillette
razors emailed me and said you have a
hundred eighty thousand followers on
Twitter we'd like to understand what
Twitter is can we pay you a consulting
fee to tell us what to do
I said yes eighty thousand dollars they
said okay that's how I got my first
client as awesome I wanted just to get
that first music story out of you you
know like to me to me there's so much in
like doing and then and then when I said
listening I had no [ __ ] idea so we
went there to talk Twitter then they're
like we're doing an activation in Las
Vegas can you do it I'm like uh-huh you
know and then I was like a [ __ ] you know
and so then I just started asking
questions I think the biggest thing and
you know 20 this goes back to how I
started this talk really I spent all my
time listening the reason I want people
to leave comments is I read them I read
all the comments I read the ones that
say that I'm the best I'm read the ones
that say that I'm the worst I read the
one and all I do is I listen it's so
funny I get made fun of one askgaryvee
because I'm always interrupting people
it's because I've gotten so good at
listening I know what the [ __ ] people
going to say before they say it I just
want to move on
you know so one of the ways to get the
next clients is to never let the last
client fail the only way not to let a
client fail is to over listen and
provide them what they want at all costs
which is why I always push against
people selling to the bottom because the
bottom doesn't know what to do with it
and then you're never going to win
you're just going to keep regurgitating
the bottom and so that's how I did it I
did it first and then I listened very
carefully to the first 20 clients to
make sure there was no chance that there
was going to be any vulnerability and I
built on the word-of-mouth of our
quality deliverables for the client also
thanks you got it Gary yes here on your
right doing it just like that lady we've
worked out together every morning for
the last year just saying no appreciate
I know you tell me the end of every
podcast
I appreciate your ear and I'm an actor
okay and I one thing that really pisses
me off of Mitchell it's a lot of people
who are here are there's a lot of actors
out there who fail their career and then
they decide they're going to open up
acting schools or they're going to you
know promise people so this career that
they never had alright so what I do I'm
very much document over create I kind of
document my own career very fortunate
the moment to be working pretty regular
I've just put another TV job recently so
I kind of like feel that I can credibly
know yeah but you know what you and I
agree on this except be careful because
I promise you I know an American
football I don't know in your football
league but I promise you some of the
best coaches of all time want good
[ __ ] players yeah these I dated his
people who have basically tried and then
just not done it and then putting
something like acting and athletics and
business is Talent
yeah you do need you do need that they
say so on talent like news alert if
there was a system that everybody would
be successful in around entrepreneurship
which means let me define
entrepreneurship for you you get to do
[ __ ] on your terms and make enough money
to do it every single [ __ ] person on
earth would
this is why I talk about self-awareness
right so I know where you're going and I
talk a lot about it as well which is
like why the [ __ ] are you buying [ __ ]
from people who've never done it right
yet but I think it's we have to be a
little careful to also know there's been
great coaches I didn't win at the
highest levels but they understood the
craft if you were a actor who went
through the process of acting school
went and tried to make it got a couple
commercials did a little Broadway did a
little stuff but never got there you
clearly got to see the people that had
it and the people that didn't have it
you might then become aware and then you
may be able to guide the problem is what
you and I hate is when somebody sucked
at it it makes pretend like they were
glasses yeah that's the problem
great coaches are like they grab you and
they say kid you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
worked every day for 15 hours a day
I [ __ ] studied everything and you got
more talent in your left foot than I
have in my whole body you need to do
this not be like me I'm [ __ ] won and
now we when they're full of [ __ ] yeah
that's that was sort of part one so stay
so what I do is then I kind of like
anytime book a job I am you know in a
meet somebody I kind of interview them
or get them on I do podcast yep
and I do two periscopes at once--that
twice a week they get uploaded to
YouTube they get the audio gets ripped
to the podcast so I'm putting content
out yep consistently all the time so
much of it for free
go ahead there's like a tiny little bit
of it that I charge a premium and
subscription for honor on a community
website that I run okay I've got a lot
of people signed up for the free stuff
they just don't think your product is
worth it to pay for well I guess they
can you give away is it possible
sometimes you're just giving away too
much for free that people I've actually
got enough coming through for free that
I don't really need to pay for anymore
because I've got enough info you know
that thing you said about the actors
yeah that if you're good enough there's
not too much as free yeah so that means
you're not good enough you can I'm scary
I've got it all but I'll be careful the
market decides if you're good enough bro
it's that it's just yeah just yes thank
you
I'm definitely gonna dope guys no no
give it give it back to him this is an
important thing because this is how you
want to win yes you're not good enough
if you're complaining about not enough
people converting no it's just saying it
is is that I think because you give away
so much and all of it that's what I mean
so you at you you never tempted to
monetize any of that oh you do those
t-shirts you know why but because you
have needs to cuz I'm good enough
yeah it's a thing like listen like I
love when people go to conferences and
like all that guy's such a great market
he's one of the best marketers am I good
[ __ ] is that person like know everybody
knows everyone I'm like great marketers
show up on [ __ ] cover of Entrepreneur
Magazine and show up on CNN and like
work with Budweiser right so like like
no I mean like here we are we're talking
about so I let you in the mic like like
I could sell plenty not only even real
[ __ ] money on the table I give people
email me and offer me $100,000 spend an
hour with me yeah like forget about your
[ __ ] 30 bucks a month horseshit I
can people to offer me a hundred
thousand dollars for an hour you know
why I'm good enough and I still say no
to that so the answer is that's it the
market is the market is the market
people write books and sell them direct
and they want to use them as gateway
drugs to other things I get paid four
million dollars to even write a book you
know why good enough
so things about it because then you can
tweak it if you actually believe that
the reason I'm forcing this one is
because I need you to believe it you
need to understand it doesn't matter
what you think about your content you're
not good enough if it's not converting
to a number that you think but you might
not be willing to do [ __ ] to convert
more because it's against your
principles and I commend you for that
but then you have to get [ __ ] good so
that it happens what you're trying to do
god ask yourself why are you even doing
that like is best you've decided that's
a good business that's fine that's great
like these are all things that play out
maybe to gave a lot more content and
mixed in some of the energy you're using
to convert into a freemium model into
maybe some content that's more about
your acting
maybe that lead to bigger roles and
you'll monetize that way then you can
arbitrage Fame and then that's the
biggest of all you know the reason I get
six figures to give a keynote everywhere
I go plus is because I give away the
other ship of free because I'm good
enough hey Gary
okay there and then we'll go to Diamond
great to see again I'll see you I run a
video business good and we're launching
a retainer but a retainer product so
they might mean you get a new video
every month it's okay what is the best
way to take that to market so it's a
high end product medium-size business
one to two million pound turnover is our
target market Facebook Facebook Ads yep
cool anything else nope I mean you'll if
it's good enough it will work there
because you can target small to
medium-sized business employees have
small to medium-size business
there's no arbitrage that's better it's
just a good bet I don't play poker you
play poker no good who plays focal raise
your hands when you're the best [ __ ]
hand you go all-in Facebook's the best
[ __ ] hand great thank you so much
real quick I apologize the key though
the key is what you're going to post in
the ad Facebook ads are the best now
you've got to make content to make
people convert but if you're doing a
video product and you're about video
then you should make the videos that are
able to convert and if you don't then
you're not good enough right like that's
the part the market the market hey my
Gary thank you um my name is Susan
Beasley I'm here with my husband Chris
we're both in our 60s we hear you talk a
lot about Millennials needing to flippin
wake themselves up yep and do something
about their lives I also made a video
for the six year olds alright thank you
guys to wake the [ __ ] up - yeah I get
bought we do it
but the point where's we're finding even
though we're champions entrepreneurship
for 50s and 60 plus but they're still
burying their heads in the sand and they
don't realize what's coming from them
and they're not going to have the
retirement that they want because
there's just no money for it what could
you say to them please I would say to
them the same thing I've been saying to
everybody which is all you can do is
tirelessly try to repackage the same
truths in whatever way you can different
adjectives different words on different
platforms with different colors and
different angles and different edits but
it's the same tried-and-true [ __ ] right
like you just listen you know you people
here watch this want to go one watches
how many people here when they first saw
my content hated me raise your hand
raisin it's okay right like you know
what you need to do is keep trying right
keep trying right
this dude hated me now he has a sign
that says Gary can you sign my shirt
please
I guess the [ __ ] fact right it's but
what's cool was it meant that I said
something a different way a different
time one more time somewhere else showed
up on some podcast that he did like the
person wait a minute why would that
person let him on when I hate that
person said something in different angle
maybe a different quote on instant
somebody shared it all you could there's
nothing I can say all you could do is
keep saying it over and over and over
and over again with different sprinkles
on top brilliant thank you you got it
I'll get you I'll get you
whoa Gaddy hey mate how do you know when
you get a opportunity when your head's
telling you that you know I've got a
massive opportunity in front of me in
the business I'm coming in but your
heart's filling you in a different part
can you do both because I push a lot of
people to both when I hear that I'm like
[ __ ] man just do me a huge favor and
audit every other hour right like that's
the tough one right when the head and
heart are aligned
when the head and heart are pulling in
opposite directions back to why I was
scared with artists right there they're
not going to be aligned that sucks
, I need to know everything you do every
hour you're awake because if I can audit
it carefully I think you might be doing
enough dumb [ __ ] that doesn't matter
that will let you do both it's like you
know it's a very interesting thing right
like like how many hours by the way I
sleep six or seven hours a night and I
think it's always funny that people
think it's a like yeah I only sleep
three hours like sleep as a non debate
like you need it so like but I'm asking
you carefully how many hours of like do
you tend to sleep tell the truth do not
lie no no it's good sleep seven like
usually place one less hour right you
just told me very passionately that your
head and your heart are pulling in
opposite directions that's worth 7 vs 8
comma how much telly do you watch how
many beers do you drink how many YouTube
videos do you watch how many [ __ ]
conferences do you come to here's what I
know I believe that you have enough time
to do both especially if any of them has
anything to do with the internet guys
every one of our grandparents didn't
have this if they had a job and they
wanted to build another business that
means they needed to be there then you
have a [ __ ] Internet we're so lucky
let's take advantage of it we're the
first generation no matter what our ages
that's living through this internet
thing that bonkers [ __ ] crazy good
that's worth shipping away you should
sit down right now not listen to a word
I'm saying and write down every [ __ ]
thing you do seven days a week
you've got family you know you've got
things people have things but you have
enough time for both yeah if we want it
oh yeah hello my name is time I feel
that the schooling system is letting a
lot of kids down okay and then you two
are awesome and so magic walnuts I wore
the magic one time let's say you had
like the blueprint which is the perfect
blueprint for for the kids for the
future and by the way real quick I
apologize [ __ ] school if you're an
entrepreneur like if you want to be a
consultant at McKinsey you better go to
[ __ ] school
this is back to self awareness I started
interrupts you like I didn't like the
way that felt
I don't want anybody think it's blind if
you know who you are let me promise you
something the number 19 employee at
Facebook made a lot more money than
everybody in this room because she was
self aware and went to a good school
that gave her a job at Facebook that
made her 400 trillion dollars got it so
keep going so let's say you have the
blueprint which enabled kids you know to
be relevant to the future especially
with tech taking yours but you
definitely don't have that no no not yet
no no not never here's why if you think
you're going to give a blueprint to a
kid that is going to allow them to be
relevant in the future tech world then
you're disrespecting the speed of tech
at a level that is even worse than the
school agreed okay but let's say you had
a better schooling system way better
than what we have now that's what is the
best way to get traction so that by not
selling parents that believe in the
school system certainty said they're
going to be sure by not trying to sell
parents that actually believe in the
school system the other the biggest
mistake that innovators I've sold [ __ ]
my whole life that nobody believes in
e-commerce then instead of going after
French Italian and California wines I
attacked New Zealand Australia Portugal
my next big win then I believe in email
instead of direct mail and newspaper
when everybody else believed them the
other way then I did Google ad words
instead of classifieds and the yellow
pages then I did YouTube blah blah and
the one consistent in my career is I
don't spend a minute trying to convince
anybody about anything
my level of giving a [ __ ] if you believe
in what I'm saying up here
is zero the mistake when people innovate
is you're trying to convince people this
is better for Johnny instead of finding
all the people that agree with us
you may go listen what's that go to the
believers then just don't even spend any
time on anybody who has any value on the
University awesome
I got him it's a really much fun about
my answer there is that is the sales tip
to every single person here the amount
of people that spend time trying to
convince people you're wasting time
these are binary decisions
ladies how quickly do you know if you're
interested in the dude when you first
meet them you knew right away
[ __ ] suckers trying to trick you
they're not going to win this is a math
game in sales you need to go where
there's opportunity instead of trying to
force people to believe in your [ __ ] and
if you're good enough then you become
historically correct I promise you one
thing my friends in here there's a lot
of people that were doing internet
marketing in 2009 in this room when I
hit the scene and started selling social
media and social media did not have
black and white ROI in two thousand six
seven eight nine ten and they didn't
believe I won so like that's why sales
and believing in what you have is so
important if you don't spend any time on
trying to sell people that don't believe
and you're right and good at your
product you win twice because you make
enough sales to get you to being in 2015
when it became obvious you were right
and then everybody else comes got it you
will read my first book it's called
crushes I wrote that [ __ ] in 2008 it
came out in 2009 everything I wrote in
that book [ __ ] happened that's just
black and white thank you so much my
camp authority granted here yeah my
question is going to be a bit weirder
perfect it's a great way to end yeah so
I flew from Bulgaria to come and see you
I'm a 23 year old aspiring entrepreneur
okay both of your books watch all your
videos can't hear what I'm doing here
now is throwing jabs at you
so literally Gary yes what would I have
to do I've message to multiple times
what are 10 times a lot of times more
important than tons give me an actual
number 10 times
I like the honesty what do I have to do
to get your attention to give me five
minutes of your time in New York to see
how you work with your philosophy done
done thank you so much hi d-roc get
example you will [ __ ] hate me right
now because I just called time on this
he's got a flight to catch it's my
wife's birthday tomorrow and if I miss
this flight I'm [ __ ] finished so I
just want to say I know you get invited
to speak events all over the world all
the [ __ ] time I don't know why you
said yes to this one I said yes because
when I looked at your [ __ ] face and I
told you stop doing horseshit events
when you said I want to I believe here
so ladies and gentlemen make some
[ __ ] noise for Gary
[Music]
[Music]